From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Morgan Smolly has been performing with an improv comedy troupe since she was in college. Look at me on page four. I somehow have my time left by now. After dozens of performances, she's learned that you need more than a creative mind to get the audience laughing.
这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR），欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。摩根·斯莫利从大学起就一直参加即兴喜剧剧团的演出。看我第四页的表现。到现在我不知怎么地还留着时间。经过几十场演出后，她明白了一件事：要想逗笑观众，光有创造力是远远不够的。
You also need to be a good listener. That means not just hearing what people say, you have to pick up on everything that surrounds the words. Like, let's say I came out and instead of saying happy birthday, like with a happy face, I could be like happy birthday, and clearly that means that I'm upset. And then we go from there like, why am I mad at them? Is it that when it was my birthday last time, they treated me like garbage, things like that?
你还得是一个很好的倾听者。这意味着不仅要听清人们在说什么，还得捕捉到言外之意的一切。比如，假设我走上台，我没有带着开心的表情说生日快乐，而是说“生日快乐”，很明显这意味着我很生气。然后我们顺着这个思路往下走，比如：我为什么生他们的气？是不是因为上次我过生日时，他们把我当垃圾一样对待，诸如此类的事情？
Morgan prides herself on being able to pick up on subtext, on being able to read between the lines, behind the lines. When she does that well, she can hear the results immediately. LAUGHTER When you get the laugh, it's just like, such a self-esteem boost. It's like instant validation. And instantly exhilarating.
摩根为自己能够捕捉到潜台词、能够透过字里行间甚至言外之意看出端倪而感到自豪。当她把这一点做好时，她能立刻听到反馈。（笑声）当你逗笑观众时，那感觉就像是对自尊心的极大提振。就像是瞬间获得的认可。而且瞬间让人兴奋不已。
That's how she felt at a recent show. There's one thing I did. I was like a slug on stage. I like got on the floor and I like acted like a slug. I inch-wormmed across the stage. Her fellow actors lit up. The audience exploded in laughter. When Morgan walked out of the theater that night, she was practically bursting.
她在最近的一次演出中就是这种感觉。我有过这么一次经历。我当时在舞台上就像一只蛞蝓。我趴在地上，装得像一只蛞蝓一样。我像尺蠖一样蠕动着穿过舞台。同台演员们的眼睛都亮了。台下爆发出雷鸣般的笑声。那天晚上摩根走出剧场时，整个人几乎兴奋得快要炸开了。
I just needed to do something with my energy. Like I didn't want to just go home and like go to sleep. Just then this guy like walked out of nowhere. He was carrying a tripod and a bunch of other stuff. Like a sack with stuff in it. And he was just like, does anybody want to buy this tripod? And I was like, yeah, I want to buy this tripod. I think I could get a lot of you set of a tripod.
我只是需要找点事来消耗一下精力。比如我不想就这么回家然后直接睡觉。就在这时，这家伙不知从哪儿冒了出来。他扛着一个三脚架和一堆别的东西。就像一个装着东西的袋子。然后他就问：“有人想买这个三脚架吗？”我就说：“行啊，我想买这个三脚架。我觉得这三脚架对我有挺大用处的。”
I was like, how much? And he said $25. And also, I'm going to give you this $50 Amazon gift card. And I was like, okay, a tripod and a $50 Amazon gift card for $25. Wow, this guy is so cool. I'm totally gonna do that. The high she fell from inch warming across the stage. Just got even higher. Morgan walked with a guy to an ATM. I got my money in 20s. So I had to either give him $20 or $40. She asked if she could give him $20.
我就问：“多少钱？”他说25美元。而且，我还送你这张50美元的亚马逊礼品卡。我就想，好吧，一个三脚架加一张50美元的亚马逊礼品卡只要25美元。哇，这人太酷了。我绝对要买。她刚才在舞台上像尺蠖一样蠕动带来的兴奋感。现在变得更强烈了。摩根跟着那个人走到一台自动取款机前。我取出来的钱都是20美元面值的。所以我只能给他20美元或者40美元。她问能不能只给他20美元。
Rather than the full 25. He was like, you give me whatever you want to give me. I was like, you're so cool. I'm going to give you $40. And I gave him $40. And then he gave me like a shoebox full of other random things. And I was like, he's so cool. Morgan felt like she had hit the jackpot.
而不是全额的25美元。他说：“你想给多少就给多少。”我当时觉得：“你太酷了，我要给你40美元。”于是我真的给了他40美元。然后他就像变戏法似地给了我一个鞋盒，里面装满了各种乱七八糟的东西。我就觉得：“他太酷了。”摩根觉得自己像是中了大奖。
There was a loofah in there. There was a bunch of pens, and I got really excited about the pens, because I don't know. I just love pens, like stress balls in there. There was like a diamond cleaner. I have never heard of a diamond cleaner before, but it's got like bristles at the end and like this juice on the inside. What else is in there?
里面有个沐浴球。还有一堆笔，我对这些笔感到兴奋得不行，因为我也说不上来。我就是喜欢笔，里面还有解压球。甚至还有一个钻石清洁剂。我以前从来没听说过钻石清洁剂，但它的前端有刷毛，里面还有类似液体的东西。里面还有什么？
It's a craft supply. I also threw in a pair of women's shoes. They weren't my size, but I was like, I could sell those. This is awesome. Morgan couldn't my size, but I was like, I can sell those. This is awesome. Morgan couldn't wait to show her roommates the loot. She burst into her apartment and told them about her unbelievable good fortune. They were like, what is wrong with you?
这是一套手工材料。我还顺便塞进了一双女鞋。虽然尺码不对，但我想着我可以把它们卖掉。这太棒了。摩根简直等不及要向室友们展示她的战利品了。她冲进公寓，向她们讲述了自己这难以置信的好运气。她们却说：“你脑子有毛病吧？”
They were like, OK, what this guy did is he took this stuff out of cars that weren't locked and then he sold it to you for money. I was like, no, no, he was so cool, no, he was so nice. He said he was moving, he was getting rid of the shoes, he said there were his girlfriend shoes, he said it was distancing himself from technology, that's why he couldn't use the gift card and he said his aunt gave him that gift card and that's why I couldn't use the gift card. And he said, his aunt gave him that gift card, and that's why he didn't want it. And slowly, like, my universe just like unraveled.
她们说：“好吧，这家伙做的事，是从没锁的车里把这些东西偷出来，然后卖给你赚钱。”我说：“不，不，他太酷了，不，他特别好。他说他要搬家了，正在处理这些鞋子，还说这是他女朋友的鞋，他说他想远离科技产品，所以才用不上这张礼品卡，他还说这张礼品卡是他姑姑送的，所以才用不上。他还说，礼品卡是他姑姑给的，所以他才不想要。”然后慢慢地，我的世界观就这么崩塌了。
And I was like, no! I just bought him a just own stuff. Why did Morgan, who prides herself on being able to read subtext and situations, fail to see what seemed obvious to her friends? I like to think of myself as like a pretty logical person, but in that moment, I didn't have any logic. Like, I wasn't questioning the situation.
当时我就想：不！我竟然花钱买了一堆别人偷来的东西。为什么擅长揣摩潜台词和局势的摩根，却没看出在朋友们看来显而易见的事情呢？我一直觉得自己是个挺理性的人，但在那一刻，我完全失去了理性。比如，我当时根本没有质疑眼前的状况。
I was just being super impulsive, and so in that way, I think I was being a pretty different person. It's as if there are two people within Morgan and neither understands the other. Logical Morgan thinks impulsive Morgan made a glaring mistake, but impulsive Morgan is just as bewildered by logical Morgan. Who would pass up a deal like this? This week on Hidden Brain, we explore how certain situations cause us to become strangers to ourselves.
我只是表现得超级冲动，所以在某种程度上，我觉得当时的自己就像换了个人似的。就好像摩根体内住着两个人，而且谁也无法理解对方。理性的摩根认为冲动的摩根犯了个显而易见的错误，但冲动的摩根对理性的摩根也同样感到困惑。谁会放着这样的便宜不占呢？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨为什么某些特定情境会让我们变得连自己都不认识自己。
I definitely didn't maintain cool and calm. My entire body froze. I was just an absolute, blubbering mess. I became filled with anger. And I just kind of lost it. And we look at the deep psychological mystery that occurs during these moments. No matter how many times we discover the strangers living inside us,
我当时绝对没有保持冷静和镇定。我的整个身体都僵住了。我当时就是一个彻底崩溃、语无伦次的糊涂虫。我充满了愤怒。然后我整个人就有点崩溃了。我们来看看这些时刻背后隐藏的深刻心理谜团。无论我们发现多少次体内住着另一个陌生人，
the next time, always catches us by surprise. Quick heads up. This episode contains stories about sex, sex work, and sexual harassment. The Pittsburgh area is home to some of the steepest hills in America. George Lohenstein used to run these hills every week with his friend Jules. We would leave our offices and run down through the park all the way down to the river and then there is a town called Greenfield with a very, very big hill. It's so steep that stairs are built into the hill to make it easier to climb. We would get absolutely exhausted on the way up and we kind of be egging one another on and be feeling very, very miserable. On the way up to the peak, all he could think of was the pain.
下一次，我们依然会被杀个措手不及。温馨提示：本期节目包含关于性、性工作和性骚扰的故事。匹兹堡地区拥有全美一些最陡峭的山坡。乔治·洛文斯坦过去常常每周和他的朋友儒勒一起跑这些山坡。我们会离开办公室，一路跑过公园，直到河边，然后那里有一个叫格林菲尔德的小镇，镇上有一座非常非常陡的山。山势太陡了，以至于人们在山上修了台阶以便攀爬。我们在上山途中累得精疲力竭，互相打气，感觉自己简直痛苦极了。在爬向山顶的路上，他脑子里想的全都是痛苦。
But moments later, it was all forgotten within maybe 10, 20 seconds. The more George thought about it, the more it seemed like a puzzle. As he was climbing the hill, the idea of relief was inconceivable. The pain felt endless. But the moment he crested the hill, the pain faded so quickly that in his memory, it hadn't been so bad.
但几分钟后，这一切都被抛到了九霄云外，也许也就是10到20秒的时间。乔治越琢磨，这事就越像是个谜。当他爬山时，想要解脱的想法简直是不可想象的。痛苦似乎永无止境。但就在他登上山顶的那一刻，痛苦消散得如此之快，以至于在他的记忆中，那其实并没有那么痛苦。
A few days later, he would lace up his shoes and go running with jewels again. It occurred to George that this gap and perception was psychologically important and applied to more than just the pain of running. I realized that when you're not in pain or cold or experiencing a powerful emotion like anger or fear, it's very difficult to imagine yourself in that situation. There is a reason this happens. Emotions completely transform us as people, so when we're in one emotional state, as if we're a different person, then we are when we're in a different emotional state.
几天后，他又会系好鞋带，和儒勒一起去跑步。乔治突然意识到，这种感知上的落差在心理学上非常重要，而且不仅适用于跑步的痛苦。我意识到，当你没有处于痛苦、寒冷或愤怒、恐惧等强烈的情绪之中时，你是很难想象自己身处那种情境之中的。这种情况的发生是有原因的。情绪彻底改变了我们作为人的本质，所以当我们处于某种情绪状态时，就好像我们变成了另一个人，而不再是我们处于另一种情绪状态时的自己。
George has thought about this phenomenon a lot. As a professor of psychology and economics at Carnegie Mellon University, he has conducted dozens of studies to understand how our emotional states affect us. One of his earliest studies involved ice water. My colleague wanted to be the guinea pig for the studies and you were supposed to put your hand in the cold water for like a minute. He put his hand on the cold water and 20 seconds later, he pulled it out. And then a minute later, he said, that's ridiculous. I can do it because he couldn't remember the pain anymore. I'm expecting fully that he would be able to sustain the minute
乔治对这种现象进行过深入的思考。作为卡内基梅隆大学的心理学和经济学教授，他开展了数十项研究，以了解我们的情绪状态是如何影响我们的。他最早的研究之一涉及冰水。我的同事想成为这项研究的白鼠，按要求你需要把手泡在冷水里大约一分钟。他把手放进冷水里，20秒后，他就把手抽了出来。然后过了一分钟，他说：“这太荒谬了。我完全能做到”，因为他已经记不得刚才有多疼了。我完全预料到他能坚持满一分钟
in the cold water. And then about 20 seconds later, he pulled his hand out again. It was just like what George experienced on his runs. As soon as his colleague pulled his hand out of the freezing water, it was like he was struck with amnesia. George came up with a name for what was happening. The hot, cold, empathy gap. The Gap. Usually when we think about empathy, we think about how we relate to other people. Georgia's insight is that we regularly lack empathy for ourselves when we are in a different
把手泡在冷水中。结果大约20秒后，他又把手抽了出来。这就像乔治跑步时的经历一样。一旦他的同事把手从冰冷的水中抽出来，他就好像得了失忆症一样。乔治为这种现象起了一个名字：冷热同理心差距（简称“差距”）。通常当我们想到同理心时，我们想到的是我们如何与他人共情。乔治的见解是，当我们处于不同的情绪状态时，我们常常对自己缺乏同理心。
emotional state. When we are angry, we can't imagine being calm. When we are tranquil, it's hard to imagine being so angry that we could hurt someone. The hot cold empathy gap can also be caused by physiological states. When we are really hungry, all our resolutions about healthy eating evaporate. When we are full, it's easy to forget what it felt like to be hungry. We imagine that we will stick to salads the next time. The hot and cold in the hot cold empathy gap are a shorthand. They describe strong emotional and physiological states.
当我们愤怒时，我们无法想象自己平静的样子。当我们平静时，也很难想象自己会愤怒到伤害别人。冷热同理心差距也可能由生理状态引起。当我们极度饥饿时，我们关于健康饮食的种种决心就会烟消云散。当我们饱腹时，我们很容易忘记饥饿时的感觉。我们会想象下一次自己一定能坚持吃沙拉。“冷热同理心差距”中的“冷”和“热”是一种简称。它们描述的是强烈的心理情绪状态和生理状态。
When we are in a cold state, we are logical, deliberate. When we are in a hot state, we're logical, deliberate. When we're in a hot state, our emotions overtake us. Morgan Smiley was in a hot state when a young man sold her a sack of random stuff. In her excitement, her skepticism failed to kick in. Another familiar hot state? Sexual arousal. Can I talk about that on MPR? I don't know. The answer is yes.
当我们处于冷静状态时，我们是理智且深思熟虑的。当我们处于冷静状态时，我们是理智且深思熟虑的。当我们处于冲动状态时，情绪会占领我们。当一个年轻人向摩根·斯莫利兜售一麻袋乱七八糟的东西时，她就处于冲动状态。在她兴奋之余，她的怀疑精神完全没有发挥作用。另一种熟悉的冲动状态是什么？性唤起。我能在NPR谈这个吗？我不知道。答案是肯定的。
So parents of young children, here's your warning. When Irene Pemberton was in middle school, she devoted as much time to sex ed as her classmates may have spent hanging out at the mall. Every Sunday evening for about a year, her parents drove her to a unitarian church for a two-hour session. We learned everything, you know, like they had the condoms, you know, putting on bananas
所以家有幼童的父母们，注意啦。艾琳·彭伯顿上初中时，她花在性教育上的时间，可能和同龄人在商场闲逛的时间一样多。大约一年的时间里，她每个星期天晚上都会让父母开车送她去一所基督一神论教堂，参加一个两小时的课程。我们学到了所有东西，你知道的，比如他们有安全套，你知道的，套在香蕉上的那种操作。
kind of deal. Irene's family also spoke frankly about sex, like the time in high school when Irene got an IUD and had a conversation about it with her mom. I just remember her saying that I still have to use condoms and, you know, to still be careful. In other words, Irene received an unusually candid, comprehensive sex education. All those hours sitting on church couches and talking to our family made her confident
艾琳的家里也开诚布公地谈论性话题，比如高中时艾琳上了节育环（IUD），并和妈妈进行了交流。我只记得她说我还是得使用安全套，你知道的，还是要小心。换句话说，艾琳接受了一份非同寻常的坦诚且全面的性教育。所有那些坐在教堂长椅上和家人交谈的时光，让她确信
that she'd made good decisions when it came to sex. I was like, well, obviously, obviously I would use condoms. Like, if I didn't know the person very and like we're not monogamous or anything and I probably was like I would do it every time. And she did. That is until she met one special suitor. He's just kind of like a like a greasy guy that like wears like overalls with no underwear and like. So I think it was cool. I thought I was pretty charmed by that. Wait, how did you know that he wears
自己在涉及性决策时会做出正确的选择。当时我想，很显然，我当然会使用安全套。比如，如果我对这个人不够了解，而且我们也不是一夫一妻制什么的，那我大概会觉得每次都会这么做。她确实也这么做了。直到她遇到了一个特别的追求者。他就像是个油腻的家伙，穿着没有内裤的工装裤之类的。所以我觉得这挺酷的。我觉得我挺被这一点吸引的。等等，你怎么知道他穿的是
overalls with no underwear? Oh yeah, that was later. That's my take on him now. Here's what happened before Irene figured out what was or wasn't beneath his overalls. We like hung out, had dinner and stuff, and then like go back to his place. And so I'm not the type of person that is just like carrying around condoms all the time. And he is the type of person that never uses condoms.
没有内裤的工装裤？哦对，那是后来才知道的。那是我现在对他的看法。以下是艾琳弄清楚他的工装裤下面到底有没有穿衣服之前发生的事情。我们一起出去玩，吃晚饭什么的，然后去了他住的地方。而且我不是那种随时随地随身带着安全套的人。而他刚好是那种从来不用安全套的人。
That was really annoying for me, but I was just like, like the conversation did not happen until we were already getting intimate. This is what all her years of sex and training had prepared her for. I'm like, oh, you don't have condoms, okay. In hindsight, Irene realizes this was exactly the situation that called for condoms.
这让我觉得真的很烦恼，但我当时就觉得，这种对话直到我们已经开始亲热时才发生。这就是她多年性教育为她做好的心理准备。我当时想，噢，你没有安全套啊，好吧。事后回想起来，艾琳意识到这正是那种必须使用安全套的情况。
Definitely the type of people that never use condoms are probably the type of people that you should use condoms with, in my opinion, at least, because they don't ever use condoms. But in that moment, a different line of reasoning went through her head. I can either choose to not have intercourse or just not have any sex at all. That was not what I really wanted to do. It didn't sound as fun. Or like do something else sexual that still just like would not be my top choice or just have unprotected sex.
在我看来，那些从来不用安全套的人，大概就是你最应该和他们使用安全套的人，至少我是这么认为的，因为他们从来都不用。但在那一刻，另一种推理在她脑海中闪过。我要么选择不和发生关系，要么就干脆什么性行为都没有。那并不是我真正想做的事。听起来没那么有趣。要么就是做点别的性行为，虽然依然不是我的首选，要么就是发生无保护的性行为。
And so I was like, this is going to be okay, like just this one time, and it's like not a big deal, and it'll be fine. And so then I did that. It's a perfect illustration of an empathy gap. This is psychologist George Lewinstein again. When you listen to her description of what happened, it's a very kind of clinical description because she, when she was talking to you, she wasn't in an aroused state. So she was talking to you as if she was really making a decision when probably in the heat
所以我当时想，没关系的，就这一次，又不是什么大不了的事，会没事的。于是我就那样做了。这是同理心差距的一个完美例证。这位又是心理学家乔治·洛文斯坦。当你听她描述发生的事情时，这是一种非常理性的描述，因为她在跟你谈论时，并没有处于被唤醒的状态。所以她跟你谈论时的样子，就好像她是在深思熟虑地做决定一样，而在当时的激情
of the moment. She was just very kind of swept up in the course of things. Irene wasn't thinking back to what her mom said about condoms. She also wasn't thinking about what she just learned in class on the history of the AIDS epidemic. Hot State Irene didn't say what cold State Irene would have predicted she would say. No one has to have sex, so I would have just said, okay, another time. I asked Irene if
关头，她其实只是被事情的发展顺理成章地裹挟了。艾琳当时并没有回想起她妈妈关于安全套的嘱咐。她也没有想起她在课堂上刚学到的艾滋病流行史。处于冲动状态的艾琳并没有说出处于冷静状态的艾琳所预言的那种话。没有人非得发生性关系，所以我当时本该说：好吧，改天吧。我问艾琳
she felt pressured into having sex. I really wanted to do it, so I feel like it was fully my choice. It was a good time. I felt like I was pretty satisfied with the results aside from me feeling like cheese that I shouldn't have done the, you know, unprotected sex part. Once the night was over, it wasn't long before cool-headed Irene reappeared. She was reading for class about the risks of unprotected sex and HIV. So, like, my brain immediately is like, oh my god, I have made a mistake. This is the one time you have unprotected sex. Like, it could be like really bad or something like that. Three days after that first date,
她是否觉得自己是被迫发生性关系的。我当时真的很想做，所以我觉得这完全是我自己的选择。那是一段不错的时光。我觉得我对结果挺满意的，除了觉得自己有点像个傻瓜，不该做那些你知道的无保护性行为。一旦那个夜晚结束，头脑冷静的艾琳很快就回来了。她当时正在阅读关于无保护性行为和艾滋病毒风险的课程资料。所以，我的大脑立刻就反应过来：天哪，我犯了个错误。这是你唯一一次发生无保护的性行为。这可能会带来非常严重的后果，诸如此类的。在那次初次约会的三天后，
she went out again with the same guy. Before the date, I really clearly told herself what would happen and what would not. Going into it, I was like, not tonight. I'm not going to have unprotected sex tonight. And then I go and hang out with him and I'm not gonna have, I'm gonna have, I'm gonna have to take this like tonight and then I go on hang out with him and I'm really distracted. The problem was, cold state Irene had not anticipated how hot state Irene would act again.
她又和同一个男人出去了。约会前，她非常明确地告诉自己什么该做，什么不该做。出发前，我心里想的是：今晚不行。今晚我绝不发生无保护的性行为。然后我去和他见面了，结果我却……我不会发生的，我得……我今晚得把这个带上，然后我去跟他见面，结果我彻底分心了。问题在于，冷静状态下的艾琳并没有预料到冲动状态下的艾琳会再次那样做。
I still did not bring condoms and I made the same choice. Although that time I was like, well, you know, that was like three days ago, and nothing bad has happened yet from that. So maybe you just one more time. Just like Morgan Smollie kind understand, why she trusted a guy selling random things on the street, Irene doesn't recognize the person who made these impulsive decisions. I was telling my friend about this and I'm like, I don't know that girl. Like I don't know her. George Lohnstein is sympathetic to Irene.
我还是没有带安全套，并且做出了同样的抉择。虽然当时我想，嗯，你知道的，那已经是三天前的事了，而且目前为止还没发生什么坏事。所以也许就再来一次吧。正如摩根·斯莫利有点难以理解，她为什么会信任一个在街头兜售杂物的陌生人一样，艾琳也认不出那个做出这些冲动决定的人了。我当时跟我的朋友谈起这事，我说：我不认识那个女孩。就像我不认识她一样。乔治·洛文斯坦对艾琳表示同情。
Sexual arousal can lead people to do things they would never expect. Downplay risks, rationalized behavior, and come up with excuses. Things that make people wake up the next day and go, oh no, what did I do? Beyond having unprotected sex with a date, sexual arousal can also drive more troubling behavior. Years ago, George ran experiments where men were given different scenarios to imagine.
性唤起会驱使人们做出他们做梦也想不到的事。淡化风险、为行为寻找借口，并找出各种理由。这些事情会让人们在第二天醒来时惊呼：天哪，我都干了些什么？除了在约会中发生无保护性行为之外，性唤起还可能驱使更令人不安的行为。多年前，乔治做过一项实验，让男性想象不同的场景。
In one study, they went on a date with a woman named Susan and things were going well in the date. At some point, they're kind of on the verge of getting into more serious physical things and Susan says she wants to stop. And we ask people, what would you do in this situation?
在一项研究中，他们和一个叫苏珊的女性去约会，约会进展得很顺利。在某个时刻，他们正处于即将发生更认真的肢体接触的边缘，而苏珊说她想停下来。我们问参与者：在这种情况下你会怎么做？
The studies put some man into a state of sexual arousal. In one experiment, the men were shown pictures of nude women. In all the studies, a control group featured men who were not sexually aroused. George found that sexually aroused men were more likely to say they would encourage a woman to drink to increase her willingness to have sex. They were more likely to say they would be willing to to drink to increase her willingness to have sex. They were more likely to say they would be willing to slip a drug into her drink. They also said that if she resisted them, they would be less likely to take no for an answer. Did men realize how their behavior changed as a result of the intervention?
这些研究让一些男性进入了性唤起状态。在一个实验中，研究人员向这些男性展示了裸体女性的照片。在所有的研究中，对照组都是没有被性唤起的男性。乔治发现，受到性唤起的男性更有可能表示，他们会鼓励女性喝酒以增加她发生性关系的意愿。他们更有可能表示，他们愿意……通过喝酒来增加她发生性关系的意愿。他们更有可能表示，他们愿意在她的饮料里偷偷下药。他们还表示，如果女性拒绝他们，他们更不会听取“不”的回答。男人们是否意识到他们的行为因这种干预而发生了改变呢？
In one experiment, George had men get sexually aroused, but then brought them back to the lab the following day. These men had time to cool down. We actually got a surprising result in that condition. The surprising result was that the men in this condition didn't just say they would respect the woman's boundaries. They indicated they would be even more mindful of consent than the men who had not been aroused. George doesn't know exactly why they got this result, but he has a guess. They can't remember how aroused they were, so they think, oh, I saw these scantily clad women and I wasn't very aroused, so probably I'd behave really well on the date. George and other researchers have repeatedly found that people are worse at predicting their behavior in a hot state, after they will already experience that hot state. These findings show the hot-called empathy gap works in two directions across time.
在一个实验中，乔治让男性产生性唤起，但随后在第二天将他们带回实验室。这些男性当时已经有时间冷静下来了。我们在那种实验条件下实际上得到了一个令人惊讶的结果。令人惊讶的结果是，处于这种条件下的男性不仅表示他们会尊重女性的底线，而且他们表现出的对同意的重视程度，甚至比那些没有被唤起的男性还要高。乔治并不确切知道他们为什么会得到这个结果，但他有一个猜测。他们记不起自己当时有多兴奋，所以他们会想：哦，我看到了这些衣着暴露的女性，但我当时并没有很兴奋，所以我可能在约会时表现得非常好。乔治和其他研究人员多次发现，人们在经历过冲动状态后，在预测自己处于冲动状态时的行为方面表现得更糟糕。这些研究结果表明，冷热同理心差距跨越时间在两个方向上都起作用。
First we're not great at predicting how we'll behave in a different emotional state. That's the prospect of empathy gap. But we also have trouble understanding our actions in the past. Our memories are faulty, especially when it comes to how intense feelings can overwhelm us. Think about George's colleague who couldn't remember how painful it felt, just one minute earlier, to have his hands submerged in icy water. So that's a retrospective empathy gap. Irene's story shows both these gaps.
首先，我们很不擅长预测自己在另一种情绪状态下的行为。这就是前瞻性的同理心差距。但我们在理解自己过去的行动时也存在困难。我们的记忆并不可靠，尤其是在强烈的情感如何压倒我们这方面。想想乔治的那位同事，他仅仅在一分钟前才把手浸入冰水中，却记不起当时有多痛了。这就是回顾性的同理心差距。艾琳的故事同时体现了这两种差距。
Before she was aroused, Irene was certain she would apply everything she had been taught by church leaders about unsafe sex. But soon after her date with the overalls guy, Cole stayed Irene could no longer put herself back into the shoes of Hot State Irene. I don't know that girl. This incomprehension led her to feel confident about how she would behave on her next day. She forgot that Hot State Irene would not be able to access her Cold State logic. This is true not just for sexual arousal. It's true for hunger, pain,
在被唤起之前，艾琳确信自己会应用教堂领袖教导她关于不安全行为的一切。但在她与那个穿工装裤的男人约会后不久，冷静状态下的艾琳就再也无法设身处地去理解冲动状态下的艾琳了。我不认识那个女孩。这种无法理解的心态让她对自己在下一次约会中的表现充满自信。她忘记了冲动状态下的艾琳将无法调用她冷静状态下的逻辑。这不仅适用于性唤起。它同样适用于饥饿、疼痛、
addiction, depression. If you are not depressed and your friend tells you, oh I feel really depressed, you might say, oh that's really terrible, I feel really sorry for you, but if you're not depressed yourself, it's really very very difficult to imagine what they're going through. This gets at one of the most troubling consequences of the hot cold empathy gap. Not only does it keep us from understanding ourselves, it can keep us from understanding other people. Feelings like hunger, thirst and anger can cause us to act impulsively. When we are in these hot states, we can say and do and think things that we would never have imagined possible even minutes earlier. But sometimes hot states don't get us fired up, they paralyze us.
成瘾、抑郁。如果你没有抑郁，而你的朋友告诉你：“哦，我觉得真的很抑郁，”你可能会说：“哦，那真的太糟糕了，我真为你感到难过。”但如果你自己没有抑郁，你是很难很难想象他们正在经历什么的。这就触及了冷热同理心差距最令人不安的后果之一。它不仅阻碍了我们理解自己，还可能阻碍我们理解他人。饥饿、口渴和愤怒等感觉会促使我们做出冲动的行为。当我们处于这些冲动状态时，我们说出、做出和想到的话，甚至可能是我们在短短几分钟前做梦也想不到的。但有时冲动状态并不会让我们情绪高涨，而是让我们陷入瘫痪。
This can be true for emotions like embarrassment or shame or fear. Nina Fuller knows this well. In her work as a psychotherapist, she often helps patients with these issues. She employs an unusual technique. I work with horses and clients. One way she does this is to bring patients into a horse's pen and have them interact with the animal. Nina pays close attention to how client and horse move together. Just watching the way a client is leading a horse like instantly, I'll be able to say you have issues with control because they're holding the horse way too tight, or if they're behind and being led by the horse and we'll discuss about how they go through the world
对于尴尬、羞耻或恐惧等情绪来说，情况往往也是如此。妮娜·富勒对此深有体会。在作为心理治疗师的工作中，她经常帮助患者解决这些问题。她采用了一种不同寻常的技术。我和马以及客户一起工作。她这样做的一种方法是将患者带入马厩，让他们与动物互动。妮娜密切关注客户和马是如何一同移动的。仅仅通过观察客户牵马的方式，我就能立刻指出：你在控制欲上有问题，因为他们把马缰绳拽得太紧了；或者如果他们落在后面、被马牵着走，我们就会讨论他们是如何在世界中
being led. Nina remembers what it was like when she started working with a client a few years ago. And the horse is eating the grass and I said, you know, just yank a little bit on the line, pull the horse's head up and start walking. And she pulls a little on the line and she looks at me and she says, the horse doesn't want to go. I'm afraid she won't like me. I said, the horse is not judging you. I guarantee you. So she pulls a little harder, nothing happens. Nina goes over and pulls the line just a little bit.
被别人牵着走的。妮娜还记得几年前她开始和一个客户工作时的情景。马正在吃草，我对她说：“你知道的，只要稍微扯一下绳子，把马的头拉起来，然后开始走就行了。”她稍微拉了一下绳子，看着我说：“马不想走。我怕它不喜欢我。”我说：“马才没有评判你呢。我向你保证。”于是她稍微用力拉了一下，什么也没发生。妮娜走过去轻轻拉了一下绳子。
And the horse's head comes up and it's like, oh, okay. And I walk around and she sees that nothing bad happened. The horse isn't mad. The woman took back the line and started walking. The silhouette of the woman's body had changed. Just as Nina instructed, she held her back and shoulder straight. She was in command of her body. The horse walked with her.
马的头抬了起来，然后她就一副“噢，原来是这样”的表情。我在周围走了一圈，她发现并没有发生什么不好的事。马并没有生气。那个女人重新握住缰绳开始往前走。那个女人的身体轮廓变了。正如妮娜所指导的那样，她挺直了背和肩膀。她掌控了自己的身体。马陪着她一起走。
And the smile on her face was one of accomplishment. Like, wow, this 1,200 pound horse is walking with me. That story is especially meaningful to Nina because there was one moment many decades ago when she did not act assertively, when she was frozen in place by embarrassment and shock. I really needed this horse therapy back then. Nina was in her early 20s studying art at George Washington University in Washington DC. But she and her husband needed part-time jobs to pay for school. She found a listing for a job in the classified section of the newspaper. I saw this.
她脸上露出了成功的微笑。就像是：哇，这匹1200磅重的马竟然在跟我一起走。这个故事对妮娜来说意义非凡，因为在几十年前，她曾有过那么一个时刻，她没有表现得坚定自信，而是被尴尬和震惊死死地冻结在原地。我当时真的很需要这种马匹疗法。妮娜当时20出头，在华盛顿特乔治·华盛顿大学学习艺术。但她和丈夫需要兼职工作来支付学费。她在报纸的分类广告版面上看到了一条招聘信息。我看到了这个。
I had to say, be a masseuse, no experience necessary. It was a way to earn money and she'd get trained on the job. Nina called the number. She was given a date and time to show up. I put my hair in the little braids and drove myself to this place and walked in. The space Nina entered looked like the waiting room of a dentist's office. Nina checked in. And somebody told me to take my hair out of the braids.
上面写着：招聘按摩师，无需经验。这是一个赚钱的途径，而且还提供在职培训。妮娜拨通了那个号码。对方给了她一个去报到的日期和时间。我把头发编成小辫子，开车去了那个地方，走了进去。妮娜进去的地方看起来像牙医诊所的候诊室。妮娜办理了登记。然后有人让我把头发从小辫子里散开。
I'm like, why would I do that? And they were like, well, I remember they said, you know, these guys that come here, they're going home to their wives. And they have high stressful jobs. And they want to relax before they go home. I'm like, ah, alright, you know. They were other women in the room. They looked about the same age as her.
我心想：我为什么要这么做？他们说，嗯，我记得他们说过：你知道的，来这里的这些男人，他们都是要回家面对妻子的。他们承受着高压的工作。他们在回家前想要放松一下。我想：啊，好吧，你知道的。房间里还有其他女性。她们看起来和她年龄相仿。
The women were asked to line up, side by side. Behind them, they were doors to massage rooms. I figured, okay, the guys come in, they pick the women and go into the room and get a massage. A man wearing a suit came in and chose Nina. She walked into one of the rooms with him. He took his clothes off. Then I gave him a massage. I mean, how do I even know how to do that?
这些女性被要求排成一排，并肩站立。在她们身后，是一扇扇通往按摩室的门。我想：好吧，男人们进来，挑选女性，然后进房间接受按摩。一个穿西装的男人走了进来，选中了妮娜。她跟着他走进了其中一个房间。他脱了衣服。然后我给他按摩。我是说，我甚至都不知道该怎么做？
I just figured what made it up as I went along. That on the job training she expected to get never happened. And then he rolled over. And I'm alone in this room with this guy. And he rolled over and he had an erection. And I was just, what? I mean, it wasn't until that point that I thought, oh, what have I gotten myself into? You know, like, what the hell?
我只是走一步算一步，现学现卖。她期望得到的在职培训根本没有发生。然后他翻了个身。我独自和这个男人呆在这个房间里。他翻过身来，居然勃起了。我当时整个人都懵了：什么？我是说，直到那一刻我才想：噢，我这是掉进什么里了？你知道的，就像是：搞什么鬼？
Nina says the man made it clear to her that he expected more than a massage. He must have said this is why I'm here. This is what you do. I mean, I think I was probably thinking, how could I not have known that? How, how, what? You know, what, oh. Nina gave in.
妮娜说，那个男人向她明确表示，他期望得到的不仅仅是按摩。他肯定说过类似“这就是我来这里的目的。这就是你要做的事”。我是说，我想我当时大概在想：我怎么会连这个都不知道？怎么会……怎么会？你知道的，怎么会这样？妮娜妥协了。
She rubbed the man's penis until he ejaculated. This is the thing that I've wondered for all these years. Like if there was an essay question, or there was a multiple choice question, and it was like, okay, this happened, and these are the choices. You stay, and you do what that man wants, you say no, I'm not doing that, what are you nuts?
她帮那个男人撸动阴茎，直到他射精。这就是我这么多年来一直在琢磨的事情。就像如果有一道论述题，或者是一道选择题，题目是这样的：好吧，事情发生了，以下是几个选项。你留下来，按照那个男人的意愿去做；你拒绝，说“我不干这个，你疯了吗？”
You leave, you get, you walk out, get in your car and drive home. I would have probably have checked, I walk out and I get in my car and I drive home. And definitely. But that's not what I did. Nina not only didn't drive off, she stayed on the job. I completed my shift, which is the part on the job. I completed my shift, which is the part that's like what in me, what in my brain, I mean, what in my whole being made me think I needed to complete that shift. I don't know that. Nina says she doesn't remember whether she gave any more mass messages that day.
你离开，去……你走出大门，上车开车回家。我大概会选择检查一下，然后走出门，坐进车里开车回家。肯定的。但事实并非如此。妮娜不仅没有开车离开，反而留下来继续工作。我完成了我的班次，这才是最让人匪夷所思的部分，就是我脑子里到底是什么，我是说，我整个生命里的什么东西让我觉得我需要完成那个班次？我也不知道。妮娜说她不记得那天自己是否还做过更多的按摩。
The rest of that evening is a blank, but the one thing she does remember is that she stayed for the whole shift. I asked her why she felt compelled to stay. When she herself would have predicted, she would do otherwise. I think I was just embarrassed to think that I had didn't know what was going on. And sort of getting your bag and walking out would have meant what, would have said what. That I had put myself in a situation that I didn't, that I had no idea what was going on when I got there. And that, and that would mean what?
那天晚上的其余时间一片空白，但她唯一记得的是，她坚持上完了整个班。我问她为什么会觉得非留下来不可。而她明明可以预测到自己本该做出不同的选择。我想我当时只是觉得很尴尬，因为觉得自己居然不知道发生了什么。而收拾包离开就意味着什么，会说明什么呢？说明我把自己置于一种我根本不知道是怎么回事、一无所知的境地。而这，那意味着什么呢？
Maybe that would mean that I was stupid. That would mean that I was stupid. You know, maybe I didn't want to appear as naive and domazai felt at that moment. Like everyone else that was there knew what they were doing, that why they were there. Yeah, maybe I didn't want to. I don't know. Maybe I didn't want to be a peer-stupid. I think that's a very common response that people say, yeah, I went through with it because clearly I should ask more on the front end and I didn't and I didn't want to look like I didn't know what I was doing so you just go through with it. This is psychologist Julie Woodzica.
也许这意味着我很愚蠢。这意味着我很愚蠢。你知道的，也许我当时不想表现得那么天真和……我当时就是这种感觉。就好像那里的所有人都知道自己在做什么、为什么要来这里。对啊，也许我不想……我不知道。也许我不想显得很蠢。我觉得这是一种非常普遍的反应，人们会说：“对啊，我之所以硬着头皮做下去，是因为很显然我在一开始就该多问问，而我没有问，我也不想显得自己什么都不懂，所以你就只能硬着头皮完成了。”这位是心理学家朱莉·伍兹卡。
I am a professor at Washington Lee University. Julie has spent years studying how people react in situations like the one Nina found herself in. Many of these people asked themselves the same questions. Why didn't I speak up? Why didn't I protest? Why did I go through with it? Some of Julie's earliest thoughts on sexual harassment and abuse came together when she
我是华盛顿与李大学的教授。朱莉花了很多时间研究人们在妮娜所遭遇的那种情境中会作何反应。许多人都会问自己同样的问题。我当时为什么不开口？我为什么不抗议？我为什么就那样顺从了？朱莉关于性骚扰和虐待的最早的一些思考，是在她成为
was a college student. Like millions of others, she witnessed the tectonic event in 1991 that brought the term sexual harassment into popular use. It was a Senate testimony of law professor Anita Hill. She claimed Supreme Court nominee Clarence Thomas had sexually harassed her while he was her supervisor. After a brief discussion of work, he would turn the conversation to a discussion of sexual matters.
一名大学生时逐渐成型的。和数百万人一样，她在1991年见证了一件具有划时代意义的事件，正是这件事让“性骚扰”一词走入大众视野。那是法学教授安妮塔·希尔在参议院的作证。她声称最高法院大法官提名人克拉伦斯·托马斯在担任她的上司期间曾对她进行性骚扰。在简短地讨论了工作之后，他会将谈话转向性相关的话题。
Before an all-male judiciary committee, she alleged he had made sexual advances and told explicit jokes. He commented on what I was wearing in terms of whether it made me more or less sexually attractive. He talked about pornographic materials. On several occasions, Thomas told me graphically of his own sexual prowess. The nation was wrapped and divided.
在全由男性组成的司法委员会面前，她指控托马斯曾对她进行性求欢并讲露骨的笑话。他会根据我穿的衣服是否让我更具有性吸引力来评头论足。他谈论色情材料。托马斯曾多次向我绘声绘色地描述他自己的性能力。整个国家为之震惊并陷入分裂。
I remember really, really vividly people saying, like, no, she's lying. She's got to be lying. There was one specific detail that led many people to that conclusion. After Anita Hill allegedly experienced harassment, she was given an opportunity to work for Clarence Thomas again. She took it. During the hearings, Senator Alan Simpson pressed her on this point. If what you say this man said to you occurred, why in God's name, when he left his position of power, or status, or authority over you, and you left it?
我非常非常清晰地记得人们说：不，她在撒谎。她一定在撒谎。有一个具体的细节让许多人得出了这个结论。在安妮塔·希尔据称遭受骚扰之后，她竟然有机会再次为克拉伦斯·托马斯工作。而她接受了。在听证会上，参议员艾伦·辛普森就这一点向她紧追不舍。如果像你所说的那样，这个男人对你说过那些话，为什么看在上帝的份上，当他离开了对你的权力、地位或权威的职位，而你也离开了之后？
In 1983, why in God's name would you ever speak to a man like that the rest of your life? That's a very good question and I'm sure that I can not answer that to your satisfaction. That is one of the things that I have tried to do today. I have suggested that I was afraid of retaliation. I was afraid of damage to my professional life. And I believe you that you have to understand that this response, and that's one of the things that I have come to understand about harassment, this response, this kind of response, is not atypical. And I can't explain. It takes an expert in psychology to explain how that can happen.
在1983年，为什么看在上帝的份上，你以后还会和这样的男人说话？这是一个很好的问题，我确信我无法给出让你满意的答案。这也是我今天试图阐述的事情之一。我曾暗示过我害怕遭到报复。我害怕我的职业生涯受到损害。我相信你必须理解这种反应，这也是我对骚扰有了更深入理解之后认识到的一点，这种反应，这种类型的反应，并不是非典型的。我也解释不清楚。这需要心理学专家来解释这种情况是如何发生的。
But it can happen, because it happened to me. By the early 2000s, Julie had become one of those experts in psychology. She and her collaborator, Mariana Lafrance, found themselves talking about how people reacted to Anita Hill's testimony. We noticed a lot of people said, I'd never would have responded that way
但它确实会发生，因为它就发生在我身上。到了2000年代初，朱莉已经成为了那些心理学专家之一。她和她的合作伙伴玛丽安娜·拉弗朗斯发现自己常常在谈论人们对安妮塔·希尔证词的反应。我们注意到很多人都说：如果我遭到性骚扰，我绝不会那样反应
if I had been sexually harassed. I would have, like, I would have told them to stop. And I probably would have left the job. I definitely would have followed him to another job. Julie realized some of the most important questions about sexual harassment had not been studied at all. There was a lot on how women remembered responding and there was a good amount on how they anticipated they would respond, but there was nothing at that point on looking at how women actually
。我会……我会让他们住手。我大概会直接辞职。我绝对不会跟着他去另一份工作。朱莉意识到，关于性骚扰的一些最重要的问题根本没有被研究过。有很多关于女性回忆自己如何反应的研究，也有相当多的研究探讨她们预判自己会如何反应，但在当时，唯独没有任何研究去审视女性实际上是如何
responded. Julie set out to understand how women react to sexual harassment as it's happening. In the first phase of the study, we had roughly 200 women come into the lab and we gave them a scenario that they needed to read through. Here's the scenario. You're interviewing for a job as a research assistant. The interviewer is in his mid-30s. You're in an office alone with him and you know after initial greeting he starts asking you some questions. They stand out interview questions until this one. Do you have a boyfriend? A few questions later. Do people find you desirable? The interview continues. Then he asks,
做出反应的。朱莉着手去了解女性在遭遇性骚扰发生时是如何反应的。在研究的第一阶段，我们让大约200名女性来到实验室，给她们提供了一个需要阅读的场景。场景如下。你正在面试一个研究助理的职位。面试官30岁出头。你独自和他在一间办公室里，你知道在最初的寒暄之后，他开始向你问一些问题。这些问题还算正常的面试问题，直到问到这个。你有男朋友吗？几个问题之后。人们觉得你有吸引力吗？面试继续进行。然后他问：
do you think it's important for women to wear bras to work? Remember, this is a job interview. The women who participated in Julie's study imagined the situation and were asked to describe how they thought they'd react. The response was overwhelming. About 90% of the women thought that they would respond in a very assertive and sometimes aggressive way. So, about 60% said that they would confront assertively, that they would say to him, that's inappropriate.
你认为女性上班穿胸罩重要吗？记住，这是一场工作面试。参与朱莉研究的女性想象了这一情境，并被要求描述她们认为自己会作何反应。结果令人大跌眼镜。大约90%的女性认为她们会以非常坚定甚至有时是攻击性的方式做出回应。因此，大约60%的人表示她们会坚定地对抗，她们会对他说：“这很不合适。”
You shouldn't ask those questions. About 30% said that they would leave the interview or that they would often say, I'd tell them off or it's slap them and then leave. Besides confronting the interviewer and leaving the interview, many participants said they do something else. 68% of all respondents said that they would refuse to answer at least one of those three questions. The women were not only asked to predict what they do, but to describe the emotion they would feel.
“你不该问这些问题。”大约30%的人表示她们会离开面试现场，或者经常说：我会把他们痛骂一顿或者扇他们一巴掌然后离开。除了对抗面试官和离开面试现场外，许多参与者表示她们会做另一件事。所有受访者中有68%表示她们会拒绝回答这三个问题中的至少一个。这些女性不仅被要求预测她们会怎么做，还被要求描述她们会感受到的情绪。
A lot of women about 30% said that they would feel anger. Women who predicted they'd be angry were more likely to say they'd confront the interviewer. Anger was galvanizing. We're interested in fear too, how many people thought they'd be a little bit afraid, and only 2% of people said that they would be afraid. And fear was not correlated with confronting. So this doesn't sound like Nina Fouler at all. These women were all assertive, angry, indignant.
许多女性——大约30%——表示她们会感到愤怒。预测自己会生气的女性更有可能表示她们会质问采访者。愤怒能起到激励作用。我们也对恐惧感兴趣，有多少人觉得自己会有点害怕，结果只有2%的人表示她们会感到害怕。而且恐惧与质问并没有关联。所以这听起来一点也不像妮娜·富勒。这些女性都十分自信、愤怒、义愤填膺。
They were sure they would tell the man off. In the second part of the study, Julie set up an experiment to test whether women actually did what they forecast they would do. We had 50 women who were applying for a job. The job was a research assistant in a lab. The women would come into the interview and we had covert cameras set up. Their interviewer was a man in his mid-30s.
她们确信自己会训斥那个男人。在研究的第二部分，朱莉设计了一个实验来测试女性是否真的会按她们预想的那样去做。我们找了50名正在申请工作的女性。这份工作是实验室的研究助理。女性会来参加面试，我们设置了隐蔽摄像头。她们的面试官是一名30多岁中年男性。
He asked those three questions. The same three questions from the first phase of the study. Do you have a boyfriend? Do people find you desirable? Do you think it's important for women to wear broad bras to work? What was different here was that the women weren't imagining a job interview, they were in a job interview, or so they believed. So how did they react? Did 90% respond assertively? Tell the interviewer off? Slap him and walk out. Nobody left. Every single person answered every single question. Some women did speak up, but generally not
他问了那三个问题。研究第一阶段时的那三个相同的三个问题。你有男朋友吗？人们觉得你有吸引力吗？你认为女性上班穿胸罩很重要吗？这里不同的是，女性们并非在想象一场工作面试，她们正处于一场工作面试中，或者她们是这么认为的。那么她们是如何反应的？有90%的人做出自信的回应了吗？训斥面试官？扇他一巴掌然后走人？没有人离开。每一个人都回答了每一个问题。有些女性确实发声了，但通常不是
until the end of the interview. 36% of the participants at that point said very politely, yeah, I was just wondering, why did you ask about me being desirable? There was another important difference between the women's responses in the two parts of the study. So you remember in the anticipated study, most women responded that they'd be angry, very few fearful, and it was the flip in this study. So we found that many women reported feeling afraid in that situation, and anger was not very much reported. While the women who imagined being sexually harassed thought they'd be angry and that anger would propel them to act,
在面试结束前。当时有36%的参与者非常礼貌地说，是的，我只是想知道，你为什么要问我有没有吸引力？女性在研究两部分中的反应还有另一个重要区别。所以你还记得在预期的研究中，大多数女性回答说她们会生气，极少数会感到害怕，而在这个研究中情况完全反转了。因此我们发现，许多女性报告说在那种情况下感到害怕，而感到愤怒的报道并不多。那些想象自己受到性骚扰的女性以为自己会生气，并且愤怒会推动她们采取行动，
women who were faced to face with a harasser, in fact experienced fear. experienced fear. This clearly an aspect of the study that should make you uneasy. Researchers brought in unsuspecting women for what they thought were job interviews, and then subjected them to harassment to see how they would behave. Julie went through rigorous ethical clearance to conduct the study. After it was over, she debriefed the volunteers and gave them the option of pulling their data. What explains the enormous gap between what women think they do and what they actually do?
而真正面对面遇到骚扰者的女性，实际上体验到的是恐惧。体验到的是恐惧。这显然是研究中应该让你感到不安的一个方面。研究人员把毫无戒心的女性请来，参加她们以为是工作面试的活动，然后让她们遭受骚扰，以观察她们会有什么行为。朱莉通过了严格的伦理审批才进行这项研究。结束后，她对志愿者进行了事后访谈，并给了她们撤回自己数据的选项。是什么解释了女性认为自己会做的事与她们实际所做的事之间巨大的差距？
When we're asked to anticipate how we would respond, we don't take into account one how our emotional state in that moment, especially if it's a highly charged moment, will impact our behavior. We're not thinking about how being in a hot state might affect us. We also don't understand very well, I think, the strength of the situation in just what would be the cost of leaving,
当我们被要求预判自己会如何反应时，我们没有考虑到两点：一是我们在那一刻的情绪状态，尤其是在高度紧张的时刻，会如何影响我们的行为。我们没有考虑处于冲动状态会如何影响我们。我认为，我们也不太理解情境的力量，比如离开的代价是什么，
how would people receive us? They're not thinking about how they're going to be feeling, they're not thinking about even really the other people in the situation. They're just thinking about what would they do. It's like wanting to build a house and showing up to the ground breaking with only a sketch, a sketch that doesn't take into consideration any of the context or any of the obstacles, like the engineering requirements or the zoning laws or the funding.
别人会如何看待我们？她们没有考虑自己将会有什么感觉，甚至没有真正考虑情境中的其他人。她们只是在考虑自己会怎么做。这就像想要建造一座房屋，却只带着一张草图出现在开工典礼上，这张草图没有考虑到任何背景或任何障碍，比如工程要求、区划法律或资金。
If you had outlined the scenario that Nina Fuller found herself in, she would have told you ahead of time that she would have walked out of the massage parlor. What she would not have been able to factor into her thinking was the change in her emotional state, her surprise, her fear, her shock, and how those emotions might have affected her ability to act. You know, if you were to think about that, you would say, oh, I'd be so mad. I'd be so mad at that guy.
如果你向妮娜·富勒概述她所处的场景，她会提前告诉你，她会直接离开那家按摩 parlor（按摩院）。她无法纳入考量的是她情绪状态的变化、她的惊讶、她的恐惧、她的震惊，以及这些情绪将如何影响她的行动能力。你知道的，如果你去想这件事，你会说，哦，我会气死。我会气死那个家伙的。
Like, what's he thinking? But in actuality, she's alone in a room with a guy. She doesn't really know like what this whole situation is except that she's been hired to give a massage and she has no experience doing that. And she's probably feeling afraid. She's not feeling angry. One thing to confront someone turns out to be just one step in actually confronting someone.
就像，他在想什么？但实际上，她和一个男人单独呆在一个房间里。她其实并不太清楚这整个情况是怎么回事，只知道自己被雇来按摩，而她完全没有这方面的经验。而且她可能感到害怕。她没有感到生气。与人对峙这回事，说到底只是真正去对峙过程中的第一步。
And it is not even the first step. First, you have to interpret that something happened that actually is sexual harassment. Then you have to interpret the event as confrontation worthy. So is this event worthy of confrontation or is it really not that big of a deal? Then you have to actually take responsibility to confront, then you have to decide, or you have to come up with different response options. What am I actually going to do? And then you actually have to do it. So when most people think about confrontation, they think about it being just one step. You know, I'm either going to confront, or I'm not going to confront. I'm going to ask it, you know, someone to make it stop or I won't.
甚至都不是第一步。首先，你必须解读出发生的事情确实是性骚扰。然后，你必须将这一事件解读为值得对峙的事件。那么，这个事件值得对峙，还是其实算不上什么大事？接着，你必须真正承担起去对峙的责任，然后你必须做决定，或者你必须想出不同的应对选项。我到底要做什么？然后你必须付诸行动。因此，当大多数人想到对峙时，他们认为这只是单一的一步。你知道的，要么我去对峙，要么我不去对峙。我要么要求某人停下来，要么不要求。
But in actuality, it's five pretty separate big steps that you have to take to be able to confront at the end. Listening to George Lohnstein and Julie Woodzica made me think about sexual harassment prevention programs. Many of these programs try to address the abuse of power that drives so much sexual harassment. But many also ignore the hot cold empathy gap. The advice given to participants is, respect other people's boundaries. Don't say and do things you would later regret. People listening might think, sure, that's easy.
但实际上，要能够最终完成对峙，你必须经历五个相当独立且重大的步骤。听了乔治·洛温斯坦和朱莉·伍兹卡的讲述，让我想到了性骚扰预防项目。其中许多项目试图解决驱动大量性骚扰的权力滥用问题。但许多项目也忽视了“冷热同理心鸿沟”。给予参与者的建议是：尊重他人的边界。不要说和做你以后会后悔的事。听众可能会想，当然，这很简单。
They're in a cold state and they can't imagine how sexual or out-zole can turn them into the kind of people who violate boundaries or may colleagues uneasy. The training programs also tell potential victims and bystanders, don't be silent. Report problems. If you see something, say something. People listening think, of course I would never be silent in a situation like that.
他们处于冷静状态，无法想象性或出格行为如何能将他们变成那种践踏边界或让同事感到不安的人。培训项目还告诉潜在的受害者和旁观者：不要沉默。举报问题。如果你看到了什么，就说出来。听众会想：我当然绝不会在那种情况下保持沉默。
They go back to their desks with the feeling that they know exactly how they would act in these situations. The hot cold empathy gap doesn't just make us draw the wrong conclusions about our actions and motivations. It can make us unfairly judge mental to what others. We hear what someone else did, someone like Anita Hill, and think, I would never have done that. I would have acted differently. It's very difficult to make sense of other people's behavior, people who are acting under
他们带着一种觉得自己完全清楚在这些情况下会如何行动的感觉回到了办公桌前。“冷热同理心鸿沟”不仅让我们对自己的行为和动机得出错误的结论，还会让我们对他人进行不公正的评判。我们听到别人做了什么，比如像安 Anita Hill（安妮塔·希尔）这样的人，然后心想：我绝不会那样做。我会采取不同的行动。要理解别人的行为是非常困难的，那些在
the influence of emotions that you're not experiencing. George Lewinstein says, our unrealistic sense of how we would act is at the root of our failure to understand others. When we assess whether and other person's actions are reasonable, we first imagine how we would behave in that situation. The problem is, our perceptions are out of whack with reality. We think we'd be able to control an addiction, or slog through pain, or confront a harasser. When we come back, we may never be able to avoid the hot cold empathy gap,
你并未体验过的情绪影响下采取行动的人。乔治·洛温斯坦说，我们对自己会如何行动的不切实际的感知，是我们无法理解他人的根源。当我们评估另一个人的行为是否合理时，我们首先想象的是自己在那种情况下会如何表现。问题在于，我们的感知与现实脱节了。我们以为自己能够控制瘾头、咬牙挺过痛苦，或者与骚扰者对峙。当我们回来时，我们可能永远无法避开“冷热同理心鸿沟”，
but there are ways to compensate for it. I was like, I don't know if this is worth it. You know, my legs hurt, my body hurts. I just want to go home and go to sleep right now. All of us see and do things we would never anticipate saying and doing. When we are in the troll of intense emotions, we are impulsive when we should be cautious. We freeze when we think we will be brave. When we look back on our behavior, we are often baffled because we have forgotten how we
但有办法去弥补它。我当时想，我不知道这是否值得。你知道的，我的腿很痛，我的身体很痛。我只想现在就回家睡觉。我们所有人都会看到并做出我们绝不会预料到自己会说会做的事情。当我们受制于强烈情绪时，我们在本该谨慎的时候却很冲动。我们在自以为会勇敢的时候却呆若木鸡。当我们回首自己的行为时，我们常常感到困惑，因为我们已经忘记了我们在
felt in the heat of the moment. Psychologist George Lowenstein calls this an empathy gap. We often can relate to the other person we become in a different emotional state. We might think that one way to bridge this gap is to see how we behave when we are in the grip of an intense emotion. Surely, after we see how we act in one of these emotional states, we won't be as naive the next time around. We think experience functions like a powerful vaccine, once inoculated, forever protected. All my research suggests that experiencing something yourself does not provide any
情绪激昂时的感受。心理学家乔治·洛温斯坦称之为同理心鸿沟。我们往往无法共情身处不同情绪状态下的另一个自己。我们可能会认为，弥补这一鸿沟的一种方法是看看我们在身处强烈情绪时的表现。当然，在我们看到自己在这些情绪状态之一下的行为之后，下一次我们就不会那么天真了。我们认为经验就像一种强效疫苗，一旦接种，终身免疫。我所有的研究都表明，亲自体验某事并不能提供任何
inoculation against the empathy gap. If experience was a simple fix, Georgia's colleague wouldn't have believed he'd be able to keep his hand in ice water the second time around. Irene would not have had unprotected sex with a no underwear and no condoms guy, twice. Most of us don't even get to the point where we recognize how different our hot and cold cells are. But even if we did, that would not be enough to change our behavior. We have to develop the muscle memory to override our instincts in those states. George has found an effective way to do so.
对同理心鸿沟的免疫力。如果经验是一个简单的解决办法，乔治的同事就不会相信自己在第二次时还能把手放在冰水里了。伊莲也不会两次都和一个不穿内衣、不带安全套的家伙发生无保护性行为。我们大多数人甚至都没有意识到我们的“热状态”自我和“冷状态”自我有多么不同。但即使我们意识到了，这也不足以改变我们的行为。我们必须培养肌肉记忆，以便在那些状态下压制我们的本能。乔治找到了一个有效的方法来做到这一点。
Training. I think what training often does is it diminishes the hot state. So, for example, when I started out in public speaking, I found it very, very painful, anxiety-making, I would get dry mouth, things like that. And then, the more I did it, the less miserable I found it. I still find radio interviews totally miserable. radio interviews totally miserable. Hahaha. Hahaha. There's an entire American institution devoted to bridging the hot cold empathy gap in situations far more physically taxing than a radio interview.
培训。我认为培训通常做的是减弱热状态。例如，当我刚开始公开演讲时，我发现它非常非常痛苦、会引发焦虑，我会口干舌燥诸如此类。然后，我做得越多，就发现它没那么痛苦了。我依然觉得电台采访完全是一场折磨。电台采访完全是一场折磨。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。有一个美国机构专门致力于在比电台采访更具身体挑战性的情境中弥合冷热同理心鸿沟。
It's the army. Military leaders have long understood that there's a way to get soldiers to perform well in battle. Put them in hot states and teach them, through repetition, to stifle their natural impulses. My name is Anastasia Fish. I'm a second lieutenant in the United States Army, and I'm an armor officer. On a February morning in 2019, Anastasia
那就是军队。军方领导人早就明白，有一种方法可以让士兵在战斗中表现出色。把他们置于热状态，并通过重复训练让他们压制自己的自然冲动。我叫阿娜斯塔西娅·菲什。我是美国陆军的一名少尉，也是一名装甲军官。在2019年2月的一个早晨，阿娜斯塔西娅
had her roommate drive her to Camp Darby in Georgia. As they approached the camp, they passed a black and yellow sign that Anastasia had seen her friends pose in front of in their Instagram photos. The sign read, not for the week or faint-hearted, it's a warning and a boast for Army Ranger School. The school puts recruits through a grueling training program. Graduates often go on to elite units and important assignments. On the first full day of training, Anastasia says she had to take a test. You have two minutes to do 49 push-ups. You have two minutes to do 59 sit-ups.
让她的室友开车送她去佐治亚州的达比营。当他们接近军营时，路过一块黑黄相间的牌子，阿娜斯塔西娅曾在她朋友们的Instagram照片里看到他们在这块牌子前摆姿势。牌子上写着：“非弱者或胆小鬼所能承受”，这是对陆军游击队员学校（Army Ranger School）的警告，也是一种夸耀。该学校对新兵进行残酷的训练。毕业生通常会进入精锐部队和承担重要任务。在训练的头一整天，阿娜斯塔西娅说她必须通过一项测试。你必须在两分钟内做49个俯卧撑。你必须在两分钟内做59个仰卧起坐。
You have 40 minutes to run five miles. And then you have to do six pull-ups right afterwards. In the weeks that followed, Anastasia had to drop from a rope into cold water and swim, wearing her full uniform. She was kept awake for hours on end. She recalls a stretch of nine days where she only got 10 hours of sleep total.
你必须在40分钟内跑完五英里。然后紧接着你必须做6个引体向上。在接下来的几周里，阿娜斯塔西娅必须穿着全套军服从绳索上跳入冷水中游泳。她连续几个小时不准睡觉。她回忆起有一段长达九天的时间里，她总共只睡了10个小时。
She was constantly distracted by hunger. Relicted some videos online of Army Ranger training, it's hard to believe human beings could survive those challenges. All this suffering had a purpose. To put trainees like Anastasia into a heart state, even though her instructors called it something else. As far as ranger school goes, they like to use the term stress inoculation,
她时刻被饥饿分心。看了一些网上关于陆军游击队员训练的视频，很难相信人类能够挺过这些挑战。所有这些痛苦都有一个目的。那就是把像阿娜斯塔西娅这样的受训者置于热状态，尽管她的教官们给它起了另一个名字。就游击队员学校而言，他们喜欢使用“压力接种”这个词，
so they create a lot of stress, and then they teach you how to live in that and how to cope with it. The stressors were both physical and psychological. She was asked to oversee a dozen people in a simulated military mission. She was asked to oversee a dozen people in a simulated military mission. She had to organize a surprise attack. At first I was very nervous about it. She had to force herself to calm down and think through
所以他们制造大量的压力，然后教你如何在这种压力中生活以及如何应对它。压力源既有生理上的，也有心理上的。她被要求在一个模拟军事任务中监督十几个人。她被要求在一个模拟军事任务中监督十几个人。她必须组织一次突袭。起初我对此感到非常紧张。她不得不强迫自己冷静下来并思考
what needed to be done. I kind of learned how to take pieces of the task and effectively execute the pieces and I could look at basically a five meter target instead of a 50 meter target. And I could take my little 5 meter targets and I could very, very easily accomplish those tasks. She used simple tools, a notebook and pen, and made checklists. And then any time that I'd start to feel kind of panicked or anxious because I was like, things aren't happening fast enough because everyone's tired. Or things aren't happening fast enough because everyone's tired. Or things aren't happening fast enough because people are distracted. I was able to look at my list and think about the things that I could check off or things
需要做什么。我有点学会了如何把任务拆解成碎片并有效地执行这些碎片，我可以基本上只看一个5米的靶子，而不是50米的靶子。我就可以把我这些小小的5米靶子设定好，然后非常非常轻松地完成这些任务。她使用了简单的工具：一个笔记本和一支笔，并制作了检查清单。然后任何时候当我开始感到有点恐慌或焦虑，因为我觉得事情进展不够快，因为大家都累了。或者事情进展不够快，因为大家都累了。或者事情进展不够快，因为大家分心了。我能够看着我的清单，思考哪些事情我可以打勾，或者哪些事情
that were going to be checked off soon. And that really actually helped me relax because I knew that things were getting done. And the more check marks I had on my list, the better I knew I was doing. Anna Stasia learned to control her behavior in different hot states, but it took weeks of round the clock training to get to that point. Few of us could handle what it takes to get our hungry, achy, exhausted selves to behave like our cold state selves. But not all challenges involve leading a team into battle. In civilian life, there can be less daunting ways to train yourself to respond to everyday challenges. Self-defense classes are designed to teach you how to respond if you are attacked. Fire drills are designed to teach you to keep your head during an emergency.
即将被勾选。这实际上真的帮我放松了，因为我知道事情正在完成。清单上打钩的项目越多，我知道自己做得就越好。阿娜斯塔西娅学会了在不同的热状态下控制自己的行为，但这需要数周全天候的训练才能达到那种地步。我们当中很少有人能应付得了让饥饿、酸痛、筋疲力尽的自己表现得像冷状态下的自己所需要付出的代价。但并非所有挑战都涉及带领团队投入战斗。在平民生活中，可以用不那么令人畏惧的方式来训练自己应对日常挑战。防身术课程旨在教你如果在遭到袭击时该如何反应。消防演习旨在教你在紧急情况下保持镇静。
Julie Woodzica is developing a training program to help women respond to sexist comments and jokes. It's called fighting fire with fire. So for instance a guy tells a sexist joke and then the woman says, wow, still single, hum-ar, which is funny, but the guy knows that like, oh, she doesn't like that. Every woman that you talk to can think of a time that they walked away from a situation where something sexist was said and you know 10 minutes later they think of the perfect comeback. Like I wish I had said this and of course in the moment you don't think of it. So we're thinking if we can have a couple that are kind of in your back pocket like can you repeat that and hear you over my eyes rolling or just things that are you know
朱莉·伍兹卡正在开发一个培训项目，以帮助女性应对性别歧视的言论和笑话。这被称为以牙还牙。所以例如一个男人讲了一个性别歧视的笑话，然后这个女人说，哇，还单身呢，幽默感真好，这很有趣，但那个男人知道，哦，她不喜欢那样。你交谈过的每个女性都能想到这样一个时刻：她们从一个说了性别歧视言论的场景中走开，然后你知道在10分钟后她们想出了完美的绝妙回击。比如我希望当时我说了这个，当然在当时那种情况下你根本想不到。所以我们在想，如果我们能准备几句像是在你后口袋里的备用话——比如你能重复一遍吗，让我翻个白眼给你看——或者只是那些你知道的
easy to say and would apply to a lot of situations, maybe we can help women to confront in more subtle ways, because it's hard to tell people that they're being sexist. Julie thinks that in a better world, women wouldn't have this burden of devising comebacks. But for the moment, these one-liners give women tools. George Lewinstein says some hot-cold situations are too challenging for us to manage as individuals. I think the solution is good public policy. Specifically he says public policy should make it easier for people in a heart state to make the same decisions they would otherwise choose in a
很简单、适用于许多情况的话，也许我们可以帮助女性以更微妙的方式进行对峙，因为要直接告诉别人他们带有性别歧视是很困难的。朱莉认为，在一个更美好的世界里，女性本不必承担想出这些回击的负担。但目前，这些单句台词为女性提供了工具。乔治·洛温斯坦说，有些冷热交替的情境对我们个人来说太具挑战性了，难以应对。我认为解决之道在于良好的公共政策。具体来说，他认为公共政策应该让处于热状态的人更容易做出他们在
cold state. Condoms he says should be quickly and easily accessible. So, for example, condoms should be kind of ubiquitously available. In other cases, George believes that policy should be designed to slow down our actions. If I got really angry at someone, I could just go down to Walmart and buy a gun today. That shouldn't be, you know, that shouldn't be possible. When you combine the instant availability of guns and empathy gaps, that's a very toxic mixture. He also sees implications for our criminal justice system
冷状态下本会选择的同样决定。他说，安全套应该能够快速且容易地获得。因此，例如，安全套应该随处可得。在其他情况下，乔治认为政策的设计应该旨在放慢我们的行动节奏。如果我对某人生气，我今天就可以去沃尔玛买一把枪。这不应该，你知道的，这不应该是可能的。当你把枪支的即时获取性与同理心鸿沟结合起来时，那是非常有毒的混合物。他还看到了这对我们的刑事司法系统的启示，
where judges and juries determine how to treat people who have acted in hot states. Take drug addiction, for example. People who have never experienced drug craving, they are not going to have any understanding of how powerfully motivating it can be. I sometimes ask my students, suppose you were addicted to heroin, can you imagine ever abandoning your children or stealing from your parents? And you know, everyone says, of course, I would never do that. But if they were addicted to heroin, it's very likely that they would do that.
法官和陪审团在那里决定如何对待处于热状态下的人。以药物成瘾为例。那些从未经历过毒瘾发作的人，是无法理解它会有多强大的驱动力的。我有时会问我的学生，假设你对海洛因上瘾，你能想象自己会抛弃孩子或偷父母的钱吗？你知道的，每个人都说，当然，我绝不会那样做。但如果他们对海洛因上瘾，他们很有可能会那样做。
So in so many of these different situations, like in the criminal justice system, it's so easy for people to condemn the behavior of people who are experiencing states that they themselves are not experiencing when they make the judgment. We might need policy to constrain our decisions, but one thing we can do on our own is to be more compassionate when we're judging others and ourselves. Nina Fuller, the woman who can't let go of that one night in the massage parlour half a century ago, doesn't consider herself judgmental of others. But for decades, she's had trouble extending such compassion to herself. I was ashamed that I wasn't a strong enough person. You know, it's just, it's actually like pulling up that horse's head off the grass.
所以在许多这样不同的情况下，比如在刑事司法系统中，人们太容易去谴责那些正在经历他们自己在做出判决时并未经历的状态的人的行为。我们可能需要政策来约束我们的决策，但我们能凭一己之力做到的一件事，就是在评判他人和自己时多一些同情。妮娜·富勒，那个半个世纪前无法放下按摩院那一夜的女性，并不认为自己爱评判别人。但几十年来，她一直难以对自己施予这种同情。我为自己不够坚强感到羞耻。你知道的，这其实就像把马的头从草地上拉起来一样。
Just pull up the horse's head off the grass and walk away. I said, no, I can't go. I got to do this. You know, I was ashamed of that. The hot cold empathy gap makes other people feel more different from us than they actually are. When someone does something we can't imagine that we would do, it's easy to be judgmental. To conclude they are weak or worse that they are bad people. This gap also makes us feel extrangers to ourselves.
只要把马的头从草地上拉起来走开就行了。我说，不，我不能走。我必须做这个。你知道的，我为此感到羞耻。冷热同理心鸿沟让其他人感觉比实际情况离我们更遥远。当某人做了我们无法想象自己会做的事时，我们很容易妄加评判。断定他们软弱，或者更糟的是他们是坏人。这种鸿沟也让我们觉得自己对自我而言成了陌生人。
So the next time we confidently announce that we would absolutely do this or we would never do that, we would be wise to remember that the people we are now are very different than the people we might become. This episode was produced by Reina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Path Shah, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Liu. Special thanks to Doyle Dean, Avery Keetley, Alex Curley and Rosanna Summers. Our run song hero is NPR's Daniel Schuchin. A few weeks ago we had some technical problems getting our podcast out into the world. No matter what we tried, the audio didn't sound quite right when we tried to upload the
所以，下一次当我们自信满满地宣布我们绝对会这样做或者我们绝不会那样做时，我们最好记住：我们现在的自己，与我们未来可能变成的自己截然不同。本期节目由雷娜·科恩（Reina Cohen）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）剪辑。我们的团队包括帕特·沙阿（Path Shah）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。特别感谢多伊尔·迪恩（Doyle Dean）、艾弗里·基特利（Avery Keetley）、亚历克斯·柯利（Alex Curley）和罗珊娜·萨默斯（Rosanna Summers）。我们的片头曲英雄是NPR的丹尼尔·舒钦（Daniel Schuchin）。几周前，我们在将播客发布到世界上时遇到了一些技术问题。无论我们尝试了什么，当我们上传节目时，音频听起来总是不太对劲。
episode. Daniel worked with us late into the evening to troubleshoot the problem and appeased the podcast gods. We're so grateful. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you have tips on how to cope with those moments when we become strangers to ourselves, share those ideas with us on social media, use the hashtag, hotcold. For me, one of the key takeaways from this episode is how our hot and cold selves don't show
丹尼尔和我们一起工作到深夜来排查问题并安抚播客之神。我们对此非常感激。想收听更多《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果您有关于如何应对我们成为自我陌生人那一刻的秘诀，请在社交媒体上与我们分享这些想法，并使用话题标签：#hotcold。对我来说，本期节目的关键收获之一是，我们的热状态和冷状态自我并没有在正确的时间出现。当我们本该保持冷静和理性时，我们往往满腔怒火且冲动行事；而当我们本该采取行动时，我们往往表现得消极或瘫痪。我想把这些想法与支持你当地公共广播电台的重要性联系起来。你的支持使像这样的故事得以成为现实，而你当地的电台在你的社区中扮演着至关重要的角色。也许你一直想捐款，但从来没有发现自己处于慷慨的热状态中。
up at the right time. When we need to be calm and logical, we're often heated and impulsive. And when we need to take action, we're often passive or paralyzed. I want to make a connection between these ideas and the importance of supporting your local public radio station. Your support makes stories like this possible and your local station plays a vital role in your community. Maybe you've always wanted to give, but never found yourself in a hot state of generosity.
好了，现在是时候做出你的年终捐赠了。访问 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。再说一遍，网址是 donate.npr.org slash hidden brain。带着万分感激，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这里是NPR。
Well, now is your time to make an end of your gift. Go to donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. Again, that's donate.npr.org slash hidden brain. With much gratitude, I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. Oh, you know, I actually used the Amazon gift card. I bought a dress and the dress came and the dress was like so ugly. And in my head I was like, okay, that's karma for buying a bunch of stolen stuff. What did you do with the dress? I just have it. I just have it. Like all the other stuff I got from that guy is just sitting in my house.
哦，你知道吗，我其实用了亚马逊礼品卡。我买了一条裙子，裙子寄到了，结果裙子丑得要命。我心里想，好吧，这就是买一堆赃物的报应。你对那条裙子做了什么？我就留着它。我就留着它。就像我从那个家伙那儿弄来的所有其他东西一样，就放在我家里。
You didn't return it to Amazon? No. Because I was like, I just serve. I just serve an ugly dress. Have you actually worn the ugly dress? No. Because I was like I just serve, I just serve an ugly dress. Have you actually worn the ugly dress? No. That would be car make punishment if you had to wear it, don't you think? That's true, maybe I should wear it so that my car was like completely satisfied. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你没有把它退给亚马逊吗？没有。因为我想，我活该。我活该得到一条丑裙子。你真的穿过那条裙子吗？没有。因为我想我活该，我活该得到一条丑裙子。你真的穿过那条裙子吗？没有。如果你不得不穿它，那才叫报应惩罚，你不觉得吗？也对，也许我应该穿上它，这样我的报应就彻底圆满了。本集节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。